der bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach war das über die aktuelle
lage in der korona pandemie und seine
ideen das infektionsschutzgesetz neu zu
ordnen eine sache hat er klargestellt
der bundesgesundheitsminister dass er
nicht pauschal die vierte impfung für
sehr junge menschen fordert und er hatte
auch noch einmal gesagt und
darauf hingewiesen dass das
infektionsgeschehen zwar schwächer wird
aktuell aber dass er sieht dass es
wahrscheinlich eine hohe dunkelziffer
gibt und dass es im herbst schon wieder
ganz anders aussehen könnte auch bei den
zahlen wir wollen diese ganzen themen
und diese ganze pressekonferenz
vertiefen mit einem gast der uns jetzt
zugeschaltet ist mal wieder hier bei
phoenix christoph specht
medizinjournalist größe nach düsseldorf
ich grüße nach bonn hallo herr specht
lassen uns versuchen das alles so ein
bisschen schritt für schritt auseinander
zu dividieren
der blick erstmal richtung herbst was
erwarten sie denn da in sachen
infektionsgeschehen in sachen nächste
corona welle na ja es wäre alles andere
als verwunderlich wenn die zahlen zum
herbst nicht ansteigen würden das hatten
wir ja in der vergangenheit jetzt immer
so gesehen auch bei ähnlichen viren auf
den anderen corona viren die hier schon
kennen das ist erwartungsgemäß die frage
ist natürlich immer welche variante ist
es und wie gut ist inzwischen unser
immunschutz in der bevölkerung aufgrund
der impfungen und natürlich auch der
durchgemachten infektionen 1 ist relativ
unwahrscheinlich aus meiner sicht dass
wir tatsächlich noch mit der gleichen
variante die jetzt zu etwa 94 prozent
dominiert doch zu tun haben das ist die
bh 5 variante die wird vermutlich naja
vielleicht bis in den herbst reichen
aber spätestens im winter rechne ich
zumindest damit dass wir eine andere
variante sehen sie sagen eine andere
variante wie könnte diese variante
aussehen das war ja immer so diese
hoffnung die im raum später dass sich
das virus in seiner deutlichkeit
beispielsweise in seiner
ansteckungsfähigkeit mehr und mehr
abschwächt wie wird das bei der nächsten
variante bei der nächsten mutation
aussehen ja das ist sicher die 100
millionen dollar frage man kann die
seriös nicht beantworten dass man sagt
genauso wird es insoweit ist das richtig
aber auf der anderen seite muss man
sagen es gibt natürlich
wahrscheinlichkeiten und man kann hier
nur mit wahrscheinlichkeiten rechnen ein
recht wahrscheinliches szenario ist dass
die reise wie wir sie jetzt in den
vergangenen zweieinhalb jahren gesehen
haben in dieser pandemie weiter geht mit
varianten die mal ein bisschen pathogene
also ein bisschen krank machen der in
der einen oder anderen richtung sind
aber im großen und ganzen weniger
pathogen werden das liegt allerdings
auch daran nicht nur an der variante
selbst sondern auch an der gesteigerten
immunität eben der bevölkerung und das
beides zusammen das lässt eigentlich die
zukunft nicht so düster aussehen wie man
vielleicht sonst allenthalben hört ja es
ist möglich dass es immer wieder
rückschläge gibt und auch das sei klar
gesagt auch an denen in
anführungsstrichen harmloser rennen
varianten können menschen sterben das
ist auch jetzt aktuell der fall das war
aber ehrlicherweise auch vor diesen saß
kopf zwei videos schon so wir haben ja
immer gerne gesagt der unterschied
zwischen der echten grippe und der
erkältungskrankheit ist an der echten
grippe können sie sterben an der
erkältungskrankheit nicht das stimmt so
sicher nicht wenn sie eine vorerkrankung
haben oder ein hohes alter erreicht
haben dann kann sie eben letztendlich
auch ein erkältungsvirus dahinraffen und
das wird auch mit saas kauf 2 in zehn
jahren noch der fall sein wie schützen
wir uns dann am besten davor dass wir
sterben wenn die korona bekommen ist es
tatsächlich die propagierte führte
impfung von minister lauterbach oder was
hilft da noch
also ist sicher nicht nur die vierte
impfung und die vierte impfungen da gibt
es ja von der stiko auch die klare
empfehlung für welche altersgruppe sie
geeignet ist es ist vor allen dingen die
erste zweite und dritte impfung das muss
man ganz klar sagen dass es der beste
schutz gegen einen schweren verlauf und
da spielt es auch nicht so sehr die
rolle das haben bisher die verschiedenen
varianten gezeigt welchen dem stoff wir
haben das ist ja immer noch der uralt
impfstoff und er wirkt aber auch was
jetzt bei 5 angeht sehr gut insofern
bräuchten wir dafür eigentlich gar nicht
den neuen impfstoff die hoffnung liegt
natürlich darauf einen dann zu haben der
besser auch die infektion zu verhindern
vermag aber da bin ich sehr vorsichtig
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass das
gelingt zumindest ist das auch noch nie
gelungen bei solchen erkältungsviren ist
ja sowieso die erste impfung die man hat
ja und was hilft uns noch tatsächlich
auch wenn man es ungern hört es ist
dieses böse wort der durchseuchung was
nichts anderes heißt kommt aus der
tiermedizin als eine steigern an
steigern der immunität also die
kombination aus impfung und das
durchmachen der infektion an denen wir
leider nicht herumkommen wie herr
lauterbach jetzt heute auch mit seiner
last gelegten stimme deutlich gezeigt
hat all diese kombination ist es die uns
letztendlich in die ende mai führen wird
wann kommen wir dann an einen punkt nach
ihrer einschätzung an dem wir uns nicht
nur im sommer locker machen das ja eben
auch eine kollege nachgefragt in der
pressekonferenz und das ist ja was was
durchaus auch im ausland links und
rechts von deutschland praktiziert wird
ganz genau sie sagen das und wenn man
zum beispiel nach dänemark schaut dann
stellt man fest dort gibt es einen wie
innen meisten ausland einen deutlich
gelassenen umgang und man kann nicht
sagen dass die irgendwie schlechter
durch die pandemie kommt das stimmt
einfach nicht ja es hat seitlich
unterschiede gegeben wir alle wissen
schweden ist gerade am anfang relativ
schlecht dagestanden mit relativ viel
todesfällen da hätte man mehr verhindern
können im langen verlauf allerdings
stehen die gar nicht so schlecht da und
die dänen haben ja zum beispiel das
impfprogramm ausgesetzt und werden es
erst im herbst wieder beginnen vor allen
dingen für die vertiefungen für die
älteren semester für die älteren
mitbürger und ich glaube das ist eine
art und weise wie man die sache auch
betrachten muss das wäre mir jedenfalls
sehr recht wenn wir es ein bisschen
gelassener sehen könnten aber diese
pandemie ist inzwischen aus meiner sicht
nicht mehr so eine medizinisch
wissenschaftliche frage sondern mehr
eine mentalitätsfrage und da sind wir
hier in deutschland eben eher auf der
etwas na ja zur panik den eigenen seite
ärztinnen und ärzte die sich überlastet
fühlen und deshalb hinschmeißen wir
sprechen weiter mit christoph specht
herr specht in ihrer arbeit was bekommen
sie denn damit was dieses thema angeht
ist es tatsächlich so dramatisch ich
sage das in anführungszeichen wie es
gerade im beitrag dargestellt wurde
naja zur einordnung muss man natürlich
sagen das sind meldungen die kommen
jetzt von der berg schafft der ärzte da
wird man nicht erwarten können dass
meldungen kommen wir sind überbezahlt
wir haben eigentlich nichts zu tun und
es geht so gut wie nie zuvor von daher
muss man glaube ich anerkennen dass hier
natürlich forderungen gestellt werden
und in der tat die arbeitsbelastung im
krankenhaus aber nicht nur bei den
ärzten ist sehr hoch und ich würde sogar
sagen auch nicht nur im krankenhaus im
gesamten gesundheitssektor aber auch in
vielen anderen bereichen wird man ja
ähnliche klagen muss man sagen wenn
jemand sagt er spielt mit dem gedanken
aus dem beruf auszusteigen
das ist ja eine befragung gewesen und
das kann man natürlich dann gern schon
mal weil man auch auf die missstände
hinweisen will mit ja beantworten auch
wenn man möglicherweise würde man 20
jahre danach noch mal nachfragen
feststellt ach gott der ist ja doch
immer noch auf derselben stelle also ja
es ist richtig die bürokratisierung vor
allen dingen nimmt sehr viel arzt zeit
weg auch übrigens von den pflegeberufen
auch bei der ambulanten pflege berufen
ist die dokumentation über bord und
geworden und das ist natürlich ein
großes problem bei dieser
hochqualifizierten arbeitszeit die dann
schwindet und eben nicht zur verfügung
steht für die patienten aber vielleicht
einsatz noch üblicherweise wird ja das
ganze dann garniert mit der forderung
wir brauchen mehr ärzte mehr medizin
studienstadt studienplätze da bin ich
nicht ganz so sicher ich glaube das
problem ist tief greifender immer mehr
ärzte immer mehr medikalisierung werde
wir müssen eine die gesamte medizin
überarbeiten und schauen ob wir da noch
auf dem richtigen pfad sind nur weil wir
dinge tun können heißt das nicht dass
sie wirklich immer indiziert sind wie
ließe sich dann aus ihrer sicht ein
bisschen druck nehmen von diesem system
ich denke nur durch einen wirklich
komplettes ankommt kompletten umbau aber
das betrifft alle das betrifft eben
nicht nur wie es immer so schön heißt
die leistungsanbieter also krankenhäuser
ärzte pflegekräfte etc sondern das
betrifft natürlich auch uns in der
mehrheit also die bevölkerung als
patienten wir haben auch da eine falsche
vorstellung was medizin in der lage ist
zu leisten und was wir alles da hinweg
delegieren könnten wir müssen mehr nicht
nur in diesem bereich aber gerade auch
in diesem bereich zur
selbstverantwortung wir müssen erkennen
dass wir zunächst einmal unser eigener
arzt sind und für unser möglichst
gesundes leben da sind ich glaube dass
die zahl der ärzte die zahl der
krankenhäuser die zahl der auch des
geldes was wir da hinein butan mehr als
eine milliarde jeden tag deutlich mehr
als eine milliarde jeden tag dass dieses
geld und diese ressourcen durchaus
ausreichen um die wirklich wichtigen
medizinischen dinge zu tun aber wir
müssen eben ein bisschen saubermachen
kehren darin und die dinge die nicht
medikalisierung gehören aus dem system
heraus nehmen christoph specht
medizinjournalist aus düsseldorf fordert
ja das system ein bisschen aufzuräumen
herzlichen dank für das gespräch